hallo leute ich zitiere mal waren und
bekommen zu einem neuen nagel video hier
in vanessas nagelstudio bessere
namensvorschläge für meinen salon bitte
nach unten in die kommentare
dankeschön da ich meinen letzten tagen
videos so gefallen hat und ich meine
skills über die letzten wochen
perfektioniert habe werde ich heute
nageldesign trends ausprobieren
zusammen mit euch ich hoffe ihr habt
spaß und holt euch ein thema denn hallo
hallo verfügbar die das ist mein
absoluter lieblingslied lings lieblings
t und zwar dass roche vanille mit einem
kleinen schuss milch und braunem zucker
schmeckt einfach meinen e gesehen gerade
furchtbar aus weil ich sie für ein
kostüm gold angemalt habe und dass nicht
mal so gut weil ich nicht so viel zeit
hat dazu sind mir noch zwei fingernägel
abgebrochen ich lerne es ja gerade noch
und die haltbarkeit meiner fingernägel
sagen wir mal so ist noch nicht ganz
perfekt es gibt für mich nichts
deprimierendes wenn ihr meine nägel
schauen sie so aussehen aber das wollen
wir heute bei style ist ihr könnt auch
manches kanal gehen und sagen dass mir
meine haare wieder werden muss er soll
bitte nach berlin kommen danke wohl
mirella kommt bald und eigentlich könnte
sie mir die haare färben meinte mirella
würde das hinbekommen schreibt es in die
kommentare aber bevor ich jetzt super
kombi market trends ob man die nägel
machen kann muss ich sie erst mal
vorbereiten und das machen wir es im
schnelldurchlauf weil ich glaube das ist
nicht so interessant also bis gleich mit
schöneren nägeln
ich muss dieses mal keine verlängerung
dran kleben weil die sind ja schon lang
und wir müssen jetzt einfach nur die
nagel aufbauen also hat man also etwas
drauf machen damit es hart und festes
und alle nageldesigner jetzt so zuerst
pinsel ich meine finger jetzt sauber
frei von staub mit meinem einhorn kinder
wir brauchen jetzt unser fiberglas
schritt eines wir nehmen jetzt fiberglas
gehe und werden eine erste schicht
machen um sie wieder schön fest zu
machen weil es schon wieder geschliffen
habe schließen sagt man muss man die
nägel schneiden schleifen feilen
wir haben uns in denen gefeilt so heißt
hat und dann einfach auch damit
[Musik]
es sieht natürlich nicht perfekt aus
muss es aber auch mich so dunkel ist
besser
da sieht man mir der name hat jetzt
fiberglas gehirn drauf und dann kommt
jetzt für 60 sekunden in den mixer und
damit meine ich irgendwie lampe ich habe
auf keinen fall bereut dieses neue set
gekauft zu haben jetzt war die beste
investition meines lebens und wenn ihr
euch viel zu lange mit der zweiten
schicht beschäftigt habt kommt wieder in
den mixer
die hand ist vorbereitet und wir können
endlich anfangen kommen wir zu unserem
ersten mal die sein was ausprobieren
möchte und zwar flammen und ihr denkt
euch jetzt flammen ja es war mit talina
nagelstudio und da hat sich kelly
schlamm auf die nägel gemacht und
seitdem sich überall auf fingernägeln
flammen das finde ich cool und das
möchte ich auch was haben wir haben rot
leon gameplay sondern eher um gelbe
flamme wäre schon cool oder wir machen
jetzt den ringfinger und zuerst kommt
rosa drauf wie vor in flammen kommt das
würde nämlich rosa o mine graz eine
frage an die nadel design community da
draußen die schafft die jetzt eure
fingernägel anzumalen ohne dass dann die
ganze puzzle und so sind hier das gefühl
umso öfter ich das set benutzt um so
mehr vorsehen sind einfach überall das
ist wirklich neongelb benutzt mal diesen
stock nageldesign stock
[Musik]
nicht mal so schlecht aus
ich glaube aber dass ich noch so ein
rand um diese flamme mache gleich einen
schwarzen dann sieht es ein bisschen
cooler aus und weil es ja cola und
lästiger wir werden schauen ich glaube
der schwarzen rand wird jetzt alles
versauen
aber das hält mich nicht davon ab das
ist ziemlich katharina egal egal
[Musik]
als ich die kamera auf gemacht habe bin
ich irgendwie noch den cent aufgekratzt
jetzt probieren wir kamen fleisch aus
und camouflage ist ja dieses kloster aus
der bundeswehr dafür nehme ich erst mal
glaube hautfarbenen nagellack als
untergrund wo man mit dem fleisch darauf
einfach in die mitte
denn dan dan dan dan dan den wilden denn
jetzt machen wir schlichtweg hier auf
mein kampf fleisch was ein bisschen
ausgelaufen ist aber auch vollkommen
okay also wir machen so flecken drauf
aber ich würde nicht so viele grün töne
gibt es auch so buntes camouflage ja
klar gibts bundeskanzlers super wir
haben jetzt unsere weise aber und da
müssen wir jetzt mal
[Musik]
ja leute viel zu erzählen gibt es nicht
mehr schön ist es nicht aber doch nicht
scheint
[Musik]
zwar senkt das sieht irgendwie aus wie
diese alten 80er 90er musen jetzt machen
wir das lustigste das macht dafür
brauchen wir einen uv top ceiling pro
gel was nicht schwitzt und jetzt seht
ihr wie man metal nägel bekommt erstmal
kommt eine schicht von diesen gilt drauf
und wir brauchen sollen lidschatten
pinsel ding und puder mitteilt oder und
hier ist das heilige puder und
eigentlich musste meinen fingern eine
jetzt schwarz sein aber uns ist das egal
wie versucht es mal so was von unseren
bruder haben wir das auf unserem abflug
war und massieren
[Musik]
wenn ihr den fingernagel schwarz drunter
machen sie das noch schöner aus und da
machen wir jetzt noch eine schicht von
unserem geld drauf also wir haben jetzt
schon metallic camouflage und flamme und
was kommt als nächstes natürlich dieser
komische war häufig habt ihr doch schon
mal gesehen sind so nägel in weiß mit so
schwarzen strichen drin ich habe keine
ahnung wie man das macht aber bestimmt
kriegen wir das hin oder
[Musik]
ich sitze hier schon wie jeder fährt so
lange also wenn ihr bei mir ein termin
habt nehmt euch ein bisschen zeit mit
das dauert bei mir ein bisschen länger
eine schicht weiß haben wir schon mal
jetzt brauchen wir noch eine zweite
schicht weiß
und jetzt machen wir eine dritte schicht
heißt aber jetzt für gehen gleich die
man kommt einfach nochmal eine
schichtweise und drauf wie kriegen wir
jetzt diesen marmor fällt also am besten
fangen wir unten an
[Musik]
das ist bis jetzt mit zwischenstopp der
letzte nagel trend den wir machen ist im
ein nagel mit ganz viel glitzer stein
drauf denn glitzersteine sind immer
trend gewesen im fingernagel business
finde ich das nur den kleinen aber
entschied jetzt in die trocknungs
maschine und jetzt brauchen wir unsere
glitzersteinchen einmal jetzt so ist es
jetzt ganz schwer zu erkennen
doch nicht in einer tour talent wow ich
bin jetzt eine richtige beauty-queen
place place place ley das finale
business
[Musik]
oh mein gott das hat gerade so lange
wieder gedauert ich glaube ich saß jetzt
hier drei stunden wenn wir eins mit
sicherheit sagen können dann das
nageldesign wirklich zeitaufwendig sind
ich finde den namen mit diesem kampf
fleisch muss da richtig cool und den
eigentlich auch mit diesen
glitzersteinen also ganz ehrlich dieser
steine wo es hingehört
das ist sowieso der aller coolste
nagellack was denkt ihr welcher
fingernagel gefällt euch am besten und
was soll ich als nächstes auf meine
nägel machen
vielleicht habt ihr ne coole idee
schreibt in die kommentare wenn euch das
video gefallen hat daumen nach oben
nicht vergessen abonnieren den kanal
denn voll viele gucken meine videos ohne
den kanal abonniert zu haben denn die
ändern
drückt den abo button und ansonsten
würde ich sagen ich hoffe ihr hattet
spaß
das video wird hoffentlich gut gewesen
sein und bis zum nächsten mal